اسعد الله اوقاتكم بكل خير واهلا بكم الى
نشره الخامسه من العربيه التي نستهلها
بابرز العناوين
جهاز الامن الفيدراليه الروسي يطلب رسميا
اعتقال مراسل جورنال لمحاكمته بتهمه
التجسس
وقائد سلاح مشاه البحريه الامريكي يقر
بافتقار واشنطن لقدره ردع الصين في المحيط
الهادي
تظاهرات جديده في عموم فرنسا ضد قانون
التقاعد ومكرون يدعو النقابات للتهدئه
ويؤكد ان الحوار مستمر
اهلا بكم الى نشره الخامسه من العربيه
قررت محكمه روسيه احتجازه مراسل جورنال
الصحفي ايفان قرش كوفيتش وذلك لمده شهرين
على ذمه التحقيق بتهمه التجسس
وخلال محاكمته اكد مراسل غورسيل انه غير
مذنب في اتهامات التجسس الموجهه اليه فيما
قال محاميه انه منع من دخول قاعه المحكمه
للاطلاع على الاتهامات
هذا من اختصاص جهاز الامن الفيدرالي لقد
اصدروا بيانا وليس لدينا ما نضيفه هنا
الشيء الوحيد الذي يمكنني قوله هو انه تم
القبض عليه بالجرم المشهور
نائب وزير الخارجيه
قال من جهته ان الوقت مازال مبكرا للحديث
عن تبادل محتمل للسجناء مع الولايات
المتحده وتحديدا مراسل صحيفه طويل
الذي اعتقل للاشتباه في ارتباطه بعمليه
تجسس لصالح الولايات المتحده
واوضح ان هذا الامر سيكون مستبعدا قبل
محاكمته وصدور حكم بشانه
ميدانيا قال رئيس منطقه دونيسك الموالي
لروسيا دينيس بوشولين ان التطويق مدينه
باخموت بالكامل بات قريبا جدا
وفي هذا السياق اوضح مسؤولون عسكريون
اوكرانيون ان القوات الروسيه احرز التقدما
في باخمت الواقعه على الجبهه الشرقيه
مضيفين ان المقاتلين الاوكرانيين ما زالوا
صامدين في المعركه
مع من موسكو لمزيد من المتابعه مراسله
العربيه كاتيا طعمي كاتي اهلا وسهلا بك
ملابسات اعتقال مراسل صحيفه
وعن اي عمليات تجسس نتحدث هنا تجسس على
سياسيين تجسس على مواقع عسكريه عن ماذا
اعتقال
المراسل صحيفه
وهي طبعا الصحيفه الامريكيه هذا المراسل
يعمل لصالح هذه الصحيفه منذ سنوات وتم
اعتقاله اليوم في مدينه
التجسس كما تحدث المسؤولون وجهاز الامن
الف
يدرالي
منذ قيامه بجمع معلومات طبعا تخص مجمع
صناعي عسكري وكما تعلم طالب هذه المعلومات
هي تعتبر من اسرار الدوله في روسيا كل ما
يتعلق بالامور العسكريه او الاسلحه هي
تعتبر من اسرار الدوله في روسيا لذلك تم
توجيه له اتهام بانه يقوم بالتجهز التجسس
لصالح
الحكومه الامريكيه صحه غطاء عمله
قالت ايضا المتحدثه الرسميه باسم الخارجيه
الروسيه اليوم الكريميوم طبعا قال انه تم
القبض عليه متلبس
[موسيقى]
ا وفي يوم انه حكم عليه الان تم اعتقاله
لمده شهرين ومنع دخول محاميه الخاص الى
جلسه
المحاكمه المغلقه التي عقدت اليوم ولم يتم
الاعلان عن امكانيه عقد جلسات اخرى
للمحكمه مع المتهم طبعا كانت الخارجيه
استبعدت امكانيه وجود عمليه تبادل او حدوث
عمليه تبادل كما قال النائب وزير الخارجيه
الروسيه قال انه من المذكر الحديث عن هذا
الموضوع الان طالب في موضوع اخر اخر
المعلومات المتوافره عن الوضع في بخموت
وهل فعلا يمكن الركن الى التقارير التي
تحدثت اليوم عن ان المدينه باتت محاصره
بالكامل من قبل القوات الروسيه
يعني كما تحدث اليوم حاكم
او حاكم دونك الانتفاليه كان قد تحدث ان
المدينه على وشك السقوط كما قال وكان الى
ذلك مرارا قد تحدث رئيس ان الوضع هناك صعب
جدا وانه يتم محاضره المدينه وليتم قطع
جميع الطرقات والامدادات عن القوات
الاوكرانيه ولكنه من اخر يتحدث عن
المقاومه كبيره ايضا من الجانب الاوكراني
هناك لذلك حتى الان هناك طبعا لا يوجد اي
تصريحات رسميه على مستوى طبعا وزاره
الدفاع
في امكانيه طبعا السيطره عليها في وقت
قريب لكن ايضا قال يوم امس ان هناك معارك
شرسه في باود وان القوات الروسيه تحاول
السيطره على المدينه
بالمعارك الشرسه ان تتجه طبعا مع الجانب
الاوكراني هناك سؤال اخير يعني دائما
التقارير الوارده من كييف تتحدث عن احتمال
شن كييف لهجوم مضاد مطلع الربيع هل تاخذ
موسكو هذه التصريحات على محمل الجد
وتتعاطى معها ام لا تراها جزء من الدعايه
الاعلاميه فقط
[موسيقى]
قال قائد سلاح مشاه البحريه الامريكيه
الجنرال ديفيد برجر ان قواته تفتقر الى
القدره الرئيسيه لتكون حاسمه في ردع صراع
مع الصين او في شن حرب بنجاح اذا اندلعت
مثل هذه الحرب في المحيط الهادئ برجر اكد
لمجله نيوزويك ان الصين هي المنافس الوحيد
القادر على الجمع بين قوتها الاقتصاديه
والدبلوماسيه والتكنولوجيه لتحدي النظام
الدولي المستقر والمفتوح الذي نتمتع
بالتواجد فيه حسب تعبيره واضاف ان الهدف
النهائي هو منع الصراع واداره الازمات في
المنطقه
وبحسب كبار قاده مشاه البحريه فان حاله
استعدادهم قد انخفضت الى ادنى مستوى لها
في السنوات الاخيره حيث بلغت نسبه التراجع
35% مما كان مطلوبا لتشكيل ثلاث مجموعات
استعداد برمائيه في كل الاوقات
لطالما شكل مضيق تايوان الذي يكتسي اهميه
استراتيجيه واقتصاديه بالغه شكل نقطه
التوتر بارزه في الصراع الحاصل بين واشنطن
التي تعتبره جزءا لا يتجزا من اراضيها
نتابع التفاصيل مع فارس صلواتي
توتر كبير خلفه الصراع في مضيق تايوان
الذي تحول لساحه حرب غير مباشره بين بكين
وواشنطن الصين تعتبر المضيق جزءا من
منطقتها الاقتصاديه ولا تعترف باستقلال
التايوان اما امريكا فتقول بان الجزء
الاكبر من المضيق يشكل مياها دوليه المضيق
عرف سابقا باسم مضيق فورموزا وهو يفصل بين
ساحل الصين وجزيره تايوان لا يتعدى طوله
180 كيلومترا كما ان اضيق جزء من هذا
المضيق يبلغ اتساعه 130 كيلومترا تقريبا
كل هذه الاجزاء تشكل حدا فاصلا بين مقاطعه
شرقي الصين وغربي جزيره تايوان التي يبلغ
عدد سكانها اربعه وعشرين مليون نسمه
التوتر المستمر منذ فتره طويله في هذا الم
نقصاها ما في وضع خط وسط يقع في منتصف
مضيق تايوان والذي تم وضعه في عام
1955 خط لا تعترف به بكين حيث يمثل حدودا
تقول تايوان بانها نطاق حدودها البحريه
وما بداخله يمثل مياهها الاقليميه وكل
تحرك للصين داخله يعد مساسا بسيادتها
وبعيدا عن جو التوترات يتمتع بضيق تايوان
باهميه تجاريه واقتصاديه كبيره فهو يعتبر
احد اهم الممرات المائيه في العالم
باعتباره قناه شحن دوليه رئيسيه يمر ما
يقرب من نصف حاويه العلم عبر ويعتبر ايضا
طريقا رئيسيا للسفن القادمه من اكبر الدول
المصنعه في اسيا كاليابان والصين وكوريا
الجنوبيه نحو نصف العالم الغربي حيث ان 88
في المئه من اكبر السفن في العالم من حيث
حمولتها مرت عبر هذا المضيق خلال عام
2022 وفقا لبيانات جمعتها وكاله بلومبرج
الخامسه مستمره فيها ايضا
في مدينه رايمون بولايه مينيسوتا
الامريكيه
اهلا بكم من جديد الى نشره الخامسه من
العربيه تنظم تظاهرات جديده اليوم في عموم
فرنسا من قبل جمعيات ومنظمات شبابيه تحمل
شعارات تدين عنف الشرطه الفرنسيه وذلك بعد
انتهاكات كثيره خلال قمع التحركات
الاحتجاجيه الاخيره التحركات تحتاج ايضا
على رفع سن التقاعد وتضامنا مع منظمه
يساريه طلبه وزير الداخليه الفرنسي حلها
رئيس الفرنسيه كان قد دعى النقابات
والمحتاجين الى التهدئه مشيرا الى ان
المجلس الدستوري سيفحص نص قانون اصلاح
نظام التقاعد بحكمه وهدوء واضاف مكروه ان
الحوار مستمر بين الحكومه والنقابات التي
لها الحق في التعبير عن رايها من خلال
التظاهرات بعيدا عن اعمال التخريب ومشاهد
العنف مؤكدا على ان الاحتجاجات الاجتماعيه
لا تعني ان كل شيء يجب ان يتوقف
موسيقى
نعلم ان هناك معارضه ضد اصلاح نظام
التقاعد لهذا السبب ستلتقي رئيسه الوزراء
بالنقابات الاسبوع المقبل وهناك تحركات
مسموح بها في اطار ديمقراطيتنا وحوار
مستمر كما ان هناك اطرا زمنيه يمكن من
خلالها تحقيق المسار الديمقراطي لمشروع
القانون ايضا هناك نص موجود في المجلس
الدستوري الذي سيدرسه بحكمه وهدوء الهدوء
مطلوب لاجراء النقاش
الى باريس لمزيد من المتابعه حول هذا
الموضوع ينضم اليه من هناك مدير مكتب
العربيه في فرنسا حسين فياضره حسين اهلا
وسهلا بك ابرز ما قاله الرئيس ماكرون
اليوم حسين
وهل يستشف من كلامه ان ثمه مسعى الى
التهدئه ام لا الكلام يستبطن مزيدا من
التصعيد
نعم اهلا بك الطالب الجوله التي قام بها
في منطقه البحيرات في اعالي الالب تحديدا
في سفين لولاك كان هدفها الاعلان عن خطه
تقشف في مجال المياه ستشمل جميع القطاعات
يجب ان يقتصد الفرنسيون في استخدام المياه
بنسبه 10% من الان وحتى العام 2030 كما
قال الرئيس معلنا تخصيص مبلغ 180 مليون
يورو لحوالي الفي بلده تعتبر اوضاعها هشه
في ظل تفاقم مشكله المياه على هامش هذه
الجوله قال الرئيس ان التحركات الحاصله ضد
اصلاح معين تحصل ضمن الاطار الذي تسمح به
ديمقراطيتنا لكن المسار الديمقراطي لنص
قانون اصلاح نظام التقاعد سيمضي الى
نهايته لا يعني وجود اطر ديمقراطيه ولا
يعني وجود هذه الاحتجاجات الاجتماعيه ان
شيء يجب ان يتوقف هذه الجمله الاخيره طالب
وهنا اعود الى سؤالك لا توحي بان ثمه
استعدادا لدى الرئيس للتراجع والارجح انه
هو كلف رسميا رئيسه الوزراء بتولي هذا
الملف ملف التفاوض مع النقبات التي رفض
مؤخرا ان يستقبل ممثليها مجددا وستستقبل
هؤلاء الممثلين للنقبات الرئيسيه رئيسه
الوزراء اليزابيث بورن الاسبوع المقبل
بانتظار حلول موعد السادس من نيسان ابريل
الذي سيكون اليوم الذي
سيصدر فيه المجلس الدستوري بحكمه فيما
يتعلق بدستوريه قانون رفع سن التقاعد اما
ان يقبل المجلس الدستوري بعض البنود فيصار
الى تعديل البعض الاخر واما ان يرفض
المجلس الدستوري كل بنود قانون نظام
التقاعد او ان يقبلها جميعا
فرضيات ثلاث ستعمل الحكومه على التعامل
معها على حسين استطرادا لما تقوله طيب اي
حديث الان عن مبادره عن حلول وسط عن وسطات
له افق جرى الحديث عن مبادره يقوم بها
نواب يمين الوسط ثم السيد جون نكمل ولكن
حتى الساعه كانت جعجعه دون طحين هل اي
حديث عن وساطه يملك اي افق ام لا الامور
ذاهبه الى مزيد من التصعيد
كانت هناك ثلاثه احتمالات فيما يتعلق
بالمفاوضات بين الحكومه والنقابات اما ان
تعمد جهه تونسيه الى التوسط بين الحكومه
والنقابات ابدت الحركه الديمقراطيه من
يمين الوسط المتحالفه مع ماكرون بعض
نوابها ابداوا استعدادا للتوسط وكان
الاحتمال الثاني ان يسار الى حوار مباشر
بين النقابات والحكومه وهذا ما سيحصل
الاسبوع المقبل فيما استبعد الاحتمال
الثالث الذي كان يقضي بان يحصل التفاوض
ولكن بعد تراجع معين من قبل الحكومه
والرئيس الرئيس والحكومه رفض التراجع
والحل الامثل سيكون من خلال المفاوضات
المباشره التي ستجري الاسبوع المقبل بين
النقبات والحكومه وسيكون هناك يوم تحرك
شعبي واسع النطاق الاسبوع المقبل سيكون
يوم الاحتجاجات الحادي عشر منذ العاشر من
شهر كانون الثاني بدء الاحتجاجات ضد رفع
سن التقاعد اشاره اخيره الى ان التحركات
التي تحدثت عنها طالب في مقدمه الخبر
ستجري امام مقر بلديه باريس عند الساعه
السابعه مساء بالتوقيت المحلي ستنظمه
الفئات شبابيه وطلابيه تعترض بشكل رئيسي
على العنف الذي تمارسه الشرطه كما تقول
هذه المنظمات الشبابيه والنقابيه ضد
المتظاهرين المشاركين في الاحتجاج على
اصنع نظام التقاعد من باريس مدير مكتب
العربيه في فرنسا حسين شكرا جزيلا لك حسين
عن كل هذه المتابعه
يعد مشروع التوسعه السعوديه الثالثه نقله
نوعيه في تاريخ المسجد الحرام بمساحه
اجماليه تصل الى قرابه مليون متر مربع
وتتسع لاكثر من 900 الف مصلي وقد شملت
التوسعه السعوديه الثالثه اربعه منارات
وعددا من القباب المتحركه والثابته باكثر
من اثنتين وعشرين قبه
من الحرم المكي الشريف ينضم اليه لمزيد من
المتابعه مراسل العربيه هاني صفيان هاني
اهلا وسهلا بك جديد المشهد بدايه من عندك
وابرز مشاهداتك اليوم
يبدو ان الاتصال مع هاني غير متوفر حتى
الساعه لنا عوده اليه في سياق هذه النشره
بعد قليل
[موسيقى]
توصل مفاوضون الاتحاد الاوروبي الى اتفاق
سياسي على اهداف اكثر طموحا
للتوسع في استخدام الطاقه المتجدده بحلول
عام 2030 ولكن في الوقت ذاتي هناك عوائق
تعرقلهم مع خططهم للطاقه النظيفه بعد حرب
اوكرانيا ومشاكل اسعار النفط
نجح الاتحاد الاوروبي المكون من 27 دوله
بالحصول على
42.5% من طاقته من مصادر متجدده مثل طاقه
الرياح والطاقه الشمسيه بحلول عشرين
ثلاثين طموحات اوروبيه في اتباع نهج خالي
من الانبعاثات الكربونيه قد لا تتم وفق
خططهم فالحرب الروسيه الاوكرانيه غيرت
المسار بعض الدول الاوروبيه عادت مجددا
للاعتماد على الفحم والوقود الاحفوري كما
حصل في المانيا مع ارتفاع اسعار الطاقه
رغبه الكتله في تخفيض الانبعاثات تقابلها
تحديات اخرى على ارض الواقع
بحسب تقرير جرين بيس ارتفعت الانبعاثات من
الطائرات الخاصه في اوروبا بشكل كبير ما
مجموعها 5.3 مليون طن من ثاني اكسيد
الكربون في السنوات الثلاث الماضيه وهذه
الكميه من ثاني اكسيد الكربون اكثر مما
تنتجه اوغندا بعدد سكاني نحو 46 مليون
نسمه في عام الباحثون وجدوا ان عدد رحلات
الطائرات الخاصه في اوروبا زاد بنسبه 64%
العام الماضي مع زياده بعثات ثاني اكسيد
الكربون باكثر من الضعف معظمها في فرنسا
وبريطانيا والمانيا كما ان للطائرات
الخاصه بعثات اعلى بكثير من وسائل النقل
الاخرى فرحله متوسطه في عام واحد تنتج
ثاني اكسيد الكربون ما يعادل قياده
السياره من باريس الى روما 16 مره وفق
التقرير
بدورها وجهت منظمه اوكسفام اصابع الاتهام
الى اصحاب الطائرات الخاصه عن مسؤولياتهم
عن انبعاثات غازات الدفيئه اكثر بمليون
مره من الشخص العادي رش خياط العربيه
اعلنت السلطات في مدينه رايموند بولايه
مينيوتا الامريكيه خروجها قطار شحن عن
مساره وقد اشتعلت النيران في بعض عربات
القطار الذي كان ينقل عددا من خزانات
تحتوي على الايثانول في حين لم تعلن
السلطات عن وقوع اصابات او ضحايا
اعود الى الحرم المكي الشريف معي من هناك
وراس العربيه نصفيان هاني اهلا وسهلا بك
جديد المشهد من عندك هاني في هذه الاوقات
وابرز مشاهداتك اليوم
طبعا الان نتواجد في التوسعه السعوديه
الثالثه هذه التوسعه التي
هي على في مراحلها الاخيره للانتهاء اليوم
نتحدث عن توسعه تسع لاكثر من 900 الف مصلي
قرابه بمساحه تتجاوز المليون متر مربع
طبعا التوسعه هي مكونه من عده ابواب اكثر
من ثمانين بابا فقط في هذه التوسعه وايضا
لو نضيف هذه المعلومه ان عدد الابواب في
المسجد الحرام ككل يتجاوز 210 ابواب طبعا
اخذ في الطابع المعماري والتصميم والاشكال
الهندسيه بشكل مختلف حيث تضيف
في تصميمه الحركه الانسيابيه وايضا الحركه
السلسه بالنسبه للمعتمرين او كذلك الحجاج
في موسم الحج اضافه الى عمليات ووحدات
التبريد ووحدات ايضا من عمليه تنقل
المعتمرين او كذلك في موسم الحج مثلا في
التطبيقات هناك توجد تطبيقات ذكيه اوجدتها
رئاسه شؤون الحرمين من خلال
بامكان الحجاج او كذلك المعتمرين
استخدامها
لطلب عربات كهربائيه او عربات عاديه ايضا
من ضمن التطبيقات والخدمات الذكيه التي
اوجدتها رئاسه شؤون الحرمين هي ايضا
تطبيقات في عمليه تنقل وانتقال المعتمر من
مكان الى اخر او كذلك الحاج في موسم الحج
من مكان الى اخر حقيقه الامر اليوم
التوسعه هي
فقط سؤال
التوسعه مكتمله تماما ام لا مازال يجري
العمل على بعض اجزائها
بدنا نتحدث اليوم عن ما نسبته 98% هي
منتهيه بالكامل ونحن نتواجد في هذه
التوسعه الاثنين في المئه بامكاننا ان
نتحدث عن التشطيبات النهائيه وهي توجد في
الخارج خارج هذه التوسعه وتحديدا في
الساحات الخارجيه وهي في المرافق الاخرى
التي تكمل اعداد المصلين
وليصلوا الى اكثر من 900 الف مصلي ممتاز
من الحرم المكي الشريف مراسل العربيه هاني
نصفيان دائما شكرا جزيلا لك هاني على كل
هذه
المتابعه ورمضان كريم دائما لك ولجميع
المشاهدين
نشط الخامسه من العربيه انتهت مزيد من
الاخبار على مواقعنا على مواقع التواصل
الاجتماعي على موقع العربيه دوت نت اطيب
التحيات والسلام عليكم ورحمه الله وبركاته